they don't have this one there's only
one to me like this man [ __ ] that man
[ __ ] you yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] you hey
it's not like they kick it off kick off
Monday with [ __ ] you when you say there
are certain words that you can say like
that
[ __ ] you well I had a teacher who had a
big mustache and when he would say [ __ ]
it would whistle through his mustache
and so he would think he was just this
giant queen and he was super he's
actually dating yeah and he would go and
and I got [ __ ] and he would say things
like that
just family Sam it would be a whistle he
giant moustache and what happened in the
scene what happened the scene Ryan
other than the fact you almost got
[ __ ] he did that to a guy who got into
wrestling that's so intense
we had a big gay dancer in our class or
he was kind of androgynous ly sexual but
he was big and he was Swedish and he was
you know much bigger six foot four and
but a ballet dancer and my one friend
was like built like me but macho and
wasn't such a good actor and he did a
scene and he attacked the ballet dancer
and a ballet dancer station yeah well
there was in there they got all
emotional and he attacked them there
were time to the scene and he's
pretending be an army guy and the
[ __ ] belly guy gets on him breaks
character goes Ryan calm down calm down
Kevin Spacey um homem holding behind the
guy's guy yeah right this second you
gotta understand there are women in the
class to the motion estimation he starts
crying until you'll still be still
mighty sire Ryan what happened here
besides the fact he almost got [ __ ]
and it was so awful it was like oh yeah
I get some food yeah
Mero died hey man listen up this is our
hey brought this on
Oh God careful careful
Mero done now listen I just got back
from the rule I've been doing the road
long enough
you're a [ __ ] Road puppy and you need
to hear this job hey new road dog you
wrote pop no hey no I'm not Road plug
well no whatever city I want do they
they were chanting no no
very important that's why I wore my
angry ultimate warrior the warrior all
right crystal ear we're talking about
this you you understand this the your
Road pop you puppy you wrote puppy
you've been on the road three times you
shut the [ __ ] up now when you ask me
question and everything hey I've been in
an ass no let me just uh my mom this
road tad Pony has some old Tony wrote
puppy now I'm Road tadpole Yas old Frodo
some we wrote totes you wrote tadpole
yeah right alright I'll take that hard
to say a couple Road toast you wrote to
let me just add some me being this young
road dad ball you been austere alright
don't be hey you've been to six
different countries and look man if I
want to do it let me know some here come
on man
did you do seven shows in Dublin three
days look I'll do a Commonwealth tour if
I have to [ __ ]
Road woman yeah we can you occurs refer
in the road war no [ __ ] way
no [ __ ] in a way I got so mad I said him
Brendan attacks I was like just a couple
things cuz you were sending me some [ __ ]
I was like you're a road puppy and don't
[ __ ] forget it and then Chris is like
yeah you're a rate jump you're like no
guys I'm a road dog I just like me
remember our Open bikers you shut the
[ __ ] up I went all the years grinding on
the road yeah we finally made a felony
Musketeers Johnny come lately the old
train hey guys I'll just take a seat in
first class you guys mob moving over
we're all I gotta what the [ __ ] is this
guy I'd say what y'all start waking up
every man in Charlotte all by myself
strolling the streets looking for dinner
I know you can see why they write those
song is bands oh yeah well I mean I
there are the times where you'd be
snowed in and [ __ ] you would be in
Kansas snowed in and we have canceled
the show they're the best is this look
we're in Kansas show I'm in the Best
Western there's nowhere to go yeah snow
and an okay so no show tonight and then
this you mind if I pay you
unless I guess there I go no I
yes I do mind he goes all right well can
I pay you a thousand like in about three
weeks
oh god there's one yeah he'll fresh nose
I got guess how you know I could live
you know I could live well a two spots
after because I'm think about moving not
out of La but just in general yeah I in
Nashville I saw a boy Wes and Jen yep
what so Western gen moved out there Wow
about a house like half an hour outside
the house I'm sure straight up on like
three acres this giant Chris $6 the kids
can run around you know they paid $18
$15 hits huge and going out there like
dang out loud something like this gasps
it's rat race I'd love this - and I get
to Columbus I'm going around I can with
him Columbus - you know one thing about
moving I mean I've been when you have
time on the road you know you look
through some [ __ ] yeah I think I mooned
Tarzana uh I have friends who live in
Tarzana I know Larry our old business
manager throwing lives near there um I
think it's a mistake you do and I'll
tell you why it's not as far as
Calabasas yeah see I think it's a I
think it's a huge mistake for you you
think yep and I'll tell you why I think
what you're drawn to is the houses yes
okay and you kind of think in y'avait
with my family and then schools and all
that stuff in for me and me which are
all do it out yeah the problem is please
know this and hear me because I've done
this and I've done it all in terms of
living everywhere right there even all
of you are in your car you will be in
your car and you will be in your car all
the time and you will never have and
you'll never and whether you know it or
not you really like having a street or
two that has everything that you can
stroll around you also now I don't
really stroll you know I'm saying yeah I
understand but also please know this
whether you know it or not
there is a difference in the air there's
a doula side where you are right now
versus I'm telling you the temperature
it's 30 degree at 20:15 degrees cooler
the air is different and there's
something about being close to the beach
even if when you don't see it that you
will never be able to
but you will feel yeah maybe I'm telling
you I mean I know I'm gonna go Scout it
out though you know it's dangerous it's
dangerous because you can get a hell of
a house and what's gonna happen in jail
son I can see myself living here and
then you're gonna live there and there
are no sidewalks and there's nowhere for
your kids to kind of mingle you know I
don't which place did you live in tartan
I'm pretty sweet I know I know there's
sidewalks
no no I know Tarzana it's amazing yeah
if-if-if what I was seeing West's place
I was like I know I know I know I know
listen this rat race were announced in
life is so busy then this is so packed
well you know it's funny also about that
as I just was talking about this today
is like when you hustle and I know
everybody out there people hostile I
people have tough lives and so yeah but
there's something about Hollywood trying
to make it in this business because it's
only up to you like this it's all up to
you right if no manager calling there's
no this try this you have to come up
with ways to make money and stay
relevant
so that means social media so that means
writing stand-up that means doing
stand-up that means traveling that means
competing that means trying to pitch a
show that means hopefully getting a show
but then you're competing with other
things is there any space on the network
you're pitching it all that stuff right
then we're managing time I got to go to
New York on Wednesday so we're trying to
figure out the podcast there's all that
stuff and I think when it's just
non-stop like that but you're always the
the only person that can solve those
problems after a while like at the end
of the week you go I'd like to move to
Italy and wear jackets and just be a
gentleman but just like three days and
then come back to it yeah like you just
need a reset yes yes and when you go out
to Nashville will you see how Americans
live will you see like like a cool
neighborhood a cul-de-sac yeah and you
see these houses and their big yards
with dogs and you go what the [ __ ] am i
doing I'm in traffic all the time you
know it's not too much I mean during the
week the weekends if you're trying to
get anywhere when everyone's out yeah
Santa Monica vet like yeah areas where
it's less size to pass yes and more and
getting more and more so and it's
expensive as [ __ ] everywhere is
expensive you don't get what you pay for
it yeah I don't know I don't know I'm
gonna snoop around there try it out yeah
we'll see
I'm going to strongly urge against it
like your new bird chopper will see
woman helicopter that might be different
it'd be a good idea cuz oh by the way
also remember I'm a homebody did this
for two years the traffic you in
Calabasas though doesn't matter at the
traffic it's not that far I'm telling
you especially there in Tarzana around
Reseda and that area or what are those
streets it gets packed I'm like the good
brother Topanga Canyon so I can go in
between the bank you know like Topanga
but again I did that for two years to
and that certain times of the day you're
stuck on that one Road certain times the
day most of the day that that artery 101
405 will see you will see in about 45
minutes you know what the 101 the 105 do
you have to take it a lot of times
especially just depend Phil Tarzana you
have to take it yeah trans Ana you want
to go up it'll get you to the 10 I'm one
thing into paying it the Pacific to give
into Venice
did it well you know it's it'll add an
hour of driving time not less
yeah and that adds up because it's two
hours of driving time there in back yeah
minimum
I promise and I it'll wear on you you'll
see if they say you know it'll wear on
you but that's me yeah we'll see you
know why don't you get out of here
you know let's try to convince them in
mood Nash from ok come on Astro man I
have to be a now via via remote control
we're skyping successful podcast does it
be two guys via Skype Matt it's just if
you if you're skyping in with each other
just don't do yeah yeah it's just not
real no and sure it'd be great I love
Wes and I would love Nashville but you
know yeah but I thought a live national
no don't get it twisted no it's pretty I
woke up this morning and I was like look
at the weather its place on earth tell
you what natural I had I walked by this
place I thought it's a Justin Bieber
concert so is the longest line you've
ever seen for these uh for a chicken
Hattie B's chicken ever heard of it huh
Hattie B's chicken never heard of it my
brother told me to go there my hotel was
a block away
mm-hmm
along this line you've ever seen for
food Hattie B's chicken so I so I walked
by and I go what do you what are you
waiting for the lead oh so chicken it's
literally the best of naturally can't
get anywhere else and so I was talking
to the fans after one of my shows on my
gamma do you know how do you have a
hookup for Hattie B's chicken and she
was just calling him go right past the
line and pick it up so I called him it
was the best chicken ever had in my life
really oh my god and you just called in
and went and picked it up Wow they were
in line for like two hours I look right
by took you to my hotel yes do you have
that scarfed it down you have the clear
yet do you have clear no clear is the
best I walk up I don't even need an idea
I just let your fingertips down look at
this [ __ ] though has different like heat
there's a mother clucking hot which I
tried burnt my mouth mother not yeah and
then I just got the regular had that
[ __ ] was delicious it's something about
fried chicken that you can't beat it
might be the greatest of all time
Nashville's food is it's up there man
it's up there yep Austin abs oh yeah
they got some good food now I could live
in Austin even though it's getting
crowded I could live in Austin I think
you think that's the other thing yeah I
think I could wherever I move you'd have
to move vice-versa
yeah that's going anywhere plus we need
to be here - yeah we do so she stand up
wise you can't be anywhere else no I
mean New York I [ __ ] hate snow so you
wanna live in a box good yeah New York
will really get to you oh yeah oh it
will help if I'm there for two days
against marching in a parade and running
a marathon every single day if you like
marching in a parade and running a
marathon every day that's living as
ten-hut
did it for you - milliony yep yeah -
bill years and it wasn't a
two-million-dollar class no yeah
and then you smell the apartment when
you when you're in a department building
that air doesn't circulate you see that
arse it's like an area it's the breath
of many nations and that's right because
everybody's booing and breathing and
then the hallway that air seeps under
the doorway not for me man no you smell
what everywhere and then you got a real
subway in please get them please get on
the subway in the summer you're pushed
up against everybody people starting
people fart farting and sweating oh
there's lots of lots of smells and then
of course you have a bum pooing in the
corner no it's all good stuff
and then what's a while [ __ ] somebody
just comes up and shoves you into a
train well you lose your foot well it
happens yeah or your face Jesus Christ
then mm-hmm yep that's right New York
City I could live without Ohio is nice
too Oh how's nice this morning I mean so
I left at 3:00 a.m. our time to get on a
flight here to make it in time for the
podcast the gentleman next to me mm-hmm
biggest human being I've ever seen
really not in a good way oh no it did
get an extension on his seatbelt oh boy
like they have this thing where they do
extension line extension yeah I've never
seen anything like it now he's literally
melting over into myself nice guy I
thought he stole my phone I fell asleep
I can't find my phone I immediately
thought is this badass he could to
connect and he go like hide it in one of
his in his fold yeah and he'd hide in
his neck
that's really true right now I know and
you'd hide in the back of hot dog you're
smuggling his neck but I well I came to
I was a little out of it I like how much
my phone I can't find it like it and he
goes well I'm looking for your phone I'm
like yeah I am so right away I'm
suspicious you know yeah but I later
found it it fell on them I got my friend
out of her this is a weird segue but
it's it's it's timely because you said
neck rolls I got my friend out of a
major Jam because he was about to move
in with his girlfriend and I lived
through a friend of ours you've met him
oh oh oh yeah and he he was about to
move his girlfriend but he had a
Colombian girlfriend on side that's at
peace and I called him I said hey hey
Bubba looking for you he might be out
with your Colombian girl but whatever
and she heard the message oh he'll be
yeah hey hey way to go I'm a dead man
and I gotta find a way out of this and
so I go okay call me up call me up and
ask me what I meant is this reason now
this is is too old for this weekend now
we were younger but it was it
was listen you know these are situations
where you're about to move on with your
girl your house is on fire
slang town drop the boy I [ __ ] I
[ __ ] my grenaded did I drop the little
grenade like you guys didn't move in
halfway around her here you go mind if I
pull the pin just drive you guys have a
good get goes on
I mean she's losing her [ __ ] so she's by
the way at the time in Austin she was on
a business trip cause up he goes hey I
go hey you guys uh you meant something
about my Colombian girl I go what he
goes my Colombian girl I go I did and he
goes yeah what were you talking about I
go I don't know I don't know if we had
the dinner he didn't I go and I go oh
[ __ ] you mean Nina the neckroll Nina the
neckroll Nina than that crawl he goes
where I go
why were you talking that girl she had
neck me and to me were talking you were
talking to her that Colombian girl that
giant Colombian girl you were talking to
her all [ __ ] night and we were looking
at her neck rolls I've never seen
anything like I went to a whole a whole
detailed story about Nina and her neck
rolls and he's good and he and and it
got him out of the [ __ ] mix I just I
just had to keep it on that girl remind
you of that long story a little long
story but I got him out of it
he called me because you're a genius I'm
good and I go well you might want to you
know nice is crazy not be with and then
that Colombian girl turned out to be she
was a hooker
well she was longer than oh but but but
then she stopped she conceived she lure
men where he was paying her and she goes
you'd have to pay me anymore but she
wanted deal Daddy Warbucks yeah and then
he decided he had to break up with her
and then she threatened to have her hurt
narcho boyfriend rise come out kill him
like God yeah so there was that it was
really good it's good stuff no more nut
rolls and then he was killed your friend
dies and he died he was pulled apart
would be nice with motorcycles how about
your boy louis ck's pulling his dick out
you know talk about a segue have you
ever had anybody like have you ever been
in a park probably not cuz you're a big
guy but I was in a park with my dog in
New York City and a guy with
Spyke people on hair was just standing
there looking at me next to a tree and
jerking off through your dog to me
looking at me and I got immediately I
was like you know dude something too
but I'm a dude so maybe what makes you
think I'm not gonna come over there and
kick you in your dick you know but I was
very it was very hurting she was so
crazy yeah I thought he probably wants
you yeah like he's is he looking to try
to like stab me and kill him [ __ ] me
so louis c.k I think he's getting lumped
into and I'm not defend what louis c.k
did it yeah it's off when I definitely
can donut and I've definitely never
jacked up front of a girl so but he has
some serious issues but you can't lump
him the same as the Harvey Weinstein
right and Brett Ratner you just can't
different animal so I think that with
Louie the way I like all bad yeah but
there's levels to this well it'd be like
yes there's level of this creep yes said
I look at Louie's thing as this weird
perversion like he's got a he's got a
bit of a perversion like a a very
strange condition like a pathology where
he gets off and he has to do it but if
if you and I are friends and I found out
you were doing that to women like you
were working with or whatever corner I
was like I'd be like Brendan Brendan
Brendan Brendan he'd be one of those
will you say my name 15 times yeah I go
Brendan Brendan Brendan Brendan Brendan
better you do it Brendan yeah what do
you then then what would the next
question me what are you doing yeah what
are you doing you can't do this and and
I feel like to me that's it's this when
I think of him doing this I think of him
having this compulsion this sad
compulsion and so it's not the jerking
off I think all of us kind of go even
the women they're like that's kind of
weird and creepy I think where the
problem lies is that he's in a position
of power you work for him and you kind
of have to deal with this kind of an
opposition part when it came out he
wasn't the Louie CK was around him like
he wasn't he was at Brett Ratner
Weinstein where he's gonna change your
career with a flick like he you know I'm
saying like I find it he's not like he's
Kevin Hart you know what Kevin Hart is
now and he goes I'm him give this role
intercept for live flight strip man he
really wasn't that big of a baller back
then don't Iran use I think he bounces
back from this what do you think I think
he bounces back yeah like I said he's in
a different league
those guys obviously a creep needs some
help I was reading this article that
this psychologist was breaking down why
guys masturbate in front of women like
that and it's one of the reasons she was
saying is it comes back to his his anger
towards women and he knows it's gonna
put him like on the defense
oh they get off on that he's it starts
from his child his mother say do that it
and the more like they're scared and the
more they're like oh like oh my god like
creeped out the better it is for them
oh man see I don't never want that I
wanted women to like then he thought he
and he thought he was kind of in the
clear cuz he would ask them before right
but you can't but by the way when you
ask them and all of a sudden you're
naked and you're you got two women who
haven't even taken their winter coats
off and they're comics and they're
standing there and you're jerking off
like it's so embarrassing I'm so
embarrassed
hideous is easy it's so embarrassing
don't you think it's like to me like to
be in the news as this person is so far
either like they found that I killed
people I think you did the right thing
by hitting it straight on like yeah I
did it yeah you have a problem I did it
yeah and then he gets over it yeah but
if you try and defend it and say no it
didn't happen like that yeah I did this
Sheik and owned this they got a no-mess
do you think that um would you rather
would you rather have Harvey Weinstein
or Lucy California if you like hat
toupee let me see
yeah me well he's like on the they're
both on first team all ugly but
Weinstein is the cat so my friend who
Jimmy Burke who's listened to the
Weinstein tape remember when he's like a
snack girl yeah he said you know what I
heard I heard a simpering addict and my
girl so my old girlfriend Katherine was
the first I could say her name now cuz I
didn't realize this she's the first girl
to come out about Harvey Weinstein so so
the the yeah so the New York Times
interviewed ER because Kim an actress
gave her name because that they were
investigating they asked an actress for
you would know and she said well my
friend had an experience and so so he
she said that it started with him
welcome to the Weinstein family she was
at Miramax she had read to read request
and another script that was big [ __ ] why
I might have been Shakespeare in Love a
camera other way it was a long time ago
so she reads these scripts and she's
beautiful she was so beautiful at 23 and
talented great dancer beautiful
in every way and he goes welcome to the
Weinstein family man you come here
anytime I have another script for you we
think you're really talented she just
done swingers and he's like you're
you're amazing and you should come to
our events you know come to our
screenings he goes in fact what are you
doing later today
this is screening today if you want and
she goes it's the early evening and you
know and she goes oh great and will come
and it was for another famous movie
camera she goes well it's not what the
remember a lot of women worked at
Miramax at the time lot of women so she
felt really safe sure and he was really
like kind of fatherly so she gets there
and it's him and her and it's more of a
movie theater it's not even a screening
so now it's like it's this is kind of a
date and he's sitting next to her and
she's like oh this is weird then she
sees a woman she knows in the business
she's like oh no this is embarrassing
she might think I'm on a date with this
guy so okay they see the movie then she
goes I'm gonna get in a cab and he goes
no can you I need to find the subway he
goes great something you know what come
up can can you call it to my house room
come up to my my apartment cuz I have a
script I want to give you and she goes
oh um no I'll wait down here and he goes
come up my wife is up there anyway just
come on up and you can say hi and stuff
like that so she goes oh okay she she
knew he had just adopted a baby so she
goes up and there's a picture of his
wife but his wife isn't there they sit
down and she did she was really
interesting she said to me she goes he
talked to me and he made me feel smart
he made me feel smart he was talking
about you know we're talking what
literature and I was 23 and I was being
taken seriously and then she gets up to
go and he goes okay
I'll walk you out but just hold on I
said let me go to the bathroom he goes
to the bathroom and comes out in a robe
and asks her for a massage and she goes
there's his back who thought maybe his
back was tight whose neck was wound up
and she goes no no I don't my fellow
massage it immediately she went oh no
she was a claimant bodied body yeah she
goes no no no no I don't know and he
goes a lot of girls have done it and he
goes through the list of actresses so
she goes oh that's fine but I'm just not
going to do that
I don't feel comfortable giving you a
massage so he goes alright well and she
goes I really have to go any look at
walking on a walk yeah he goes back in
the bathroom comes out naked takes
another lobe comes out naked
Anton's up lose all that antes up she
goes she goes and he's a big guy she
goes I'm gonna get raped
here it is I'm about to be raped long
story short he stopped he got in the
front of the door where the door was and
behind the couch yes he doubled down and
what she said was interesting though she
said that he was begging like like so
she would go why are you doing this how
can you do this because I know you're
right you're right I'm sorry I'm sorry
I'm sorry
I'll put my clothes on but just show me
your tits you know it was like that he
was like an addict like okay you're
right you're right here I won but can
you just show me your ass like it was
that and then he would say it was like
this i begging where she was like what
are you doing how are you doing this
it's this is so wrong and gross you had
me come and now you're in this and your
wife lives here this is me because I
know I know it's terrible I'm a PC yeah
they say the psychologist they recognize
themselves as worthless and pieces of
[ __ ] yes so then when he does it it kind
of qualifies him like verifies you know
I am a piece of [ __ ] I'm doing this
again right and so he so yeah even by
her own admission it was like it was
almost like this yeah yeah titties
hanging out it's spot on your body and I
used to think the way she did retold the
story cuz when she told you Stu think I
used to tell a story as Salma Hayek was
there but she wasn't so that was a
complete I told the whole a totally
different story because that you knew
you but I got the full story from her I
talked to her this this this weekend is
a bummer and and that was what happened
she was alone finally oh this is even
crazier so finally finally he puts on
his clothes he puts on a Saturday it's a
night he begs forgiveness he begs her
forgiveness you know I'll put you in
movies and everything else and she's
standing there and she's like any and he
goes running back in the bathroom she
she thinks about bolting but he like I'm
begging you please I'm begging please
forgive me please I'll never do this
again please forgive me and she's a
really good person right and so she's
like [ __ ] all right let me get out of
here he comes out of his clothes on he
goes to get her a cab and he gets in the
cab with her dad dog and then Nate
arrives you dude he drives her down she
jumps
out to a bar downtown she runs in and
says to the bartender just New York
bartender she goes please talk to me
like you know me please talk to me like
the minute you know me and she her hands
are shaking and and the bartenders in
New York guys like what are you please
just to please talk to me like manically
she he watched her through the window in
the cab for like 15 minutes he didn't
leave
well that's so that's the story he's
crazy that's the full story from her and
she was the first person to come out cuz
she was like you know I haven't told
anybody showed me and a couple of people
yeah but but but she and really when she
told me the stories tell me that she
chased her around like a cow so I
thought it was in a hotel room but it
was a Turner I was in his place
long story short she when the New York
Times came and asked her she thought
about not saying anything she says you
know I'm almost 50 I'm not really in the
business anymore let's kick this thing
yeah she had and she didn't make any
money he never paid her off or anything
like no no no rolls in oh no she was so
talented but and she she thinks that
it's because every time she would see
him she would get sweaty locked up you
know cortisol you know and and also you
know the it triggers yeah triggers it's
right he's just bad dude he's fat dude
he's super whereas someone like louis
c.k I feel you know I don't condone it
but I think it's more of a sickness I
got weird like kind of a yeah like why
do I think they're all sick pathetic
Kanak with right yeah there's two
daughters two it's a really but uh I
used to see them I used to walk my dog
by his house every day is a beautiful
crazy if you're Lucy Kay how many years
did he grind grind grind grind and never
made it never made it never made it he's
always in the room traveling he's on the
road doing this to us
and one talked about how talent is never
made it just the guy just guy then
cocoon blows up and then you jacked up
front of girls and all that's down the
block his deal with FX is special on HBO
special on Netflix I know the the Louie
show all that gone it's that's it's that
joke about the guys like ludus man I
build a wall I build a 25-foot wall with
stone and they don't call me the stone
though the wall maker you see that jetty
that goes out at all the boats dock on I
spent day
night for a year making that jetty and
that's where people come they don't call
me the jetty maker you know look at that
house I've made all these as I'm an
architect I built all these incredible
houses it took me my lifetime and
everybody lives in them and I've been I
want all these awards but you [ __ ] one
goat one goat now in fighting now they
call you the gull if I'm gonna seek a
[ __ ] ZK like all that all those
years of hard work
yeah you [ __ ] one go your first one go I
jack off in front of a few goats yeah
and your whole career that's it I think
he's gonna bounce back I bet in like
three or four years let me ask you this
Oh bounce back because you ran to Louise
one of those guys who owned a lot of his
own content released on his own website
just to his fans it is a pretty loyal
fanbase and again I think what he did is
traumatizing towards those women but it
but is it though I don't know I let me
play it that with a few and cheering
back miracle rents are jacking off
you're gonna probably have trouble
sleeping tonight yeah now now I can beat
the [ __ ] out of both of you and I'd
still be like oh my god if you drag off
if you imagine if you're a feat now
imagine if I do that - MJ I'm waiting -
what do you MJ get on the mic about this
I want your perspective on a woman's
perspective on this so if you're working
with a guy like Louie and you're a
female comic and you're a grown woman
and he jerks off in his office and in
front of you what what is that what
happens there and in your mind
I mean you've not been there maybe you
have but I know it well I would think
either about to put up with this I'm
losing my job would hamantaschen are you
gonna be very interesting so she just
said that sexual harassment at the end
of the day yeah you have to put up with
it or you can lose your job it's
generally sexual her I was coercion yeah
you're forced to deal with it mm-hmm
yeah if you while working and keep your
mouth shut right of course
so yeah that's that's where that's where
that's where I think that's the crux of
it is that you put them in that position
but again it went at the time when louis
c.k did so I'm not defending understand
when he did this he wasn't V louis c.k
we know and I remember who his manager
was yeah yeah and I by the way Rebecca
shout-out today Becky I gotta what say
this about day Becky Dave Becky got me
started in this business I've known Dave
Dave Becky for 24 years 25 years Dave
Becky is an impeccable human being and
Dave Beck
for him to be caught up in this and they
say you know heave never threaten
anybody I mean that did any any any it's
very hard for Dave to be wrapped up in
this because Dave Becky if you look at
all the monsters he represents they've
been with him from day one and he's been
with them from day one and that's
because Dave Becky is one of the good
guys in this business all the way
through and anybody who's a comment
anybody who's in this no no I'm just
telling it this is important it's
important it is important because we
also don't know the detail no but I I do
write this yes and I do know the details
and more importantly I really know Dave
and this is really important to say
because because there there is there was
the insinuation that Dave and three arts
would have blackballed you okay
anyone who knows Dave and and I don't
want it I don't want to speak for the
details but as far as Dave's reputation
and as a person from what I know and I
know him well and I know people that
know him very well
Dave Dave Becky is an impeccable human
being were sort of the biggest in the
world and he's and he's a great [ __ ]
dude and I think it's just the whole
thing is a [ __ ] nightmare for him too
but he's also really loyal and if you
know that your client has this weird
compulsive what do you do in this
situation you talk to him you probably
say what the [ __ ] are you doing I don't
know well I don't know how he handled
that then that's where I can't defend a
rocky I don't know you don't work with
them I don't need anything from them the
thing is when when the thing about life
and think about louis c.k and this has
been going on for years and years and
years yeah so as a manager as part of
his team someone should have played some
sort of control they probably did they
probably did probably they wore like a
matte or remember a lot of this stuff is
hearsay remember that - nobody wants to
talk about it I'll tell you right now if
if I had this problem and they're like
man Shabet comes to his jacked off for
the people that jobs doing this job
doing this it's Christ my manager my
team would sit me down go hold on yeah
we were just hearing some stuff
are you [ __ ] Jack and out front of
people you haven't remember this that's
what I mean it was all kind of rumor
like everybody was he kind of hear what
you know it'd be like yeah yeah but but
after years and years and years rumors
become the norm they source from
somewhere
weird it's not like the one time where
there's smoke there's fire but it's not
at one time where the smoke there's fire
how do you deal with that how do you how
do you when somebody says you know III
wasn't in the room and I don't know what
kind of talks they had that's why I
can't defend anyone I would have to talk
to Dave about yeah yeah yeah yeah you
would yeah that's why I'm defending
these guys I defend Dave Becky as a
person and then as a professional and as
a guy with a tough situation it's a
tough situation it's a very [ __ ]
tough situation and I think I think
Louie recognizes that and you know and I
don't know Louie I don't know I've said
for worse to Louie in my life but you
don't had any of that Jason we gotta
turn a jackoff on you know nothing to
that extent thankfully no I mean there
has been like some some stances where I
knew the guy was being overly creepier
overly touchy I've had some managers
that would like hey you're doing an
awesome job today and would like touch
the girl's legs and then and then
obviously I mean you just be a stuff and
like minimal stuff like restaurants and
whatnot I've never had you know a good
office job to where I felt threatened I
was gonna lose my job or I had to be
flirty towards my boss yeah that's where
the whole problem yeah if you're putting
people in a position where they might
lose their job or they have to put up
with it that's where you got a problem
what do you think Kevin space he bounces
back ever no he does not know that why
because of the 14 year old raped a dude
14 year old no that's not homeboy said
he raped them no no no no he did no no I
just read it he did he said he came back
and Kevin Spacey tried to rape him not
only dimma his way said he picked him up
carried him across the threshold likes a
different one put him on the ground
system on a bad is a different case it's
a different guy in New York Kevin Spacey
was working at a like a Playhouse
something and he was one of the guys and
they were in a relationship and he was
young as [ __ ] right I don't he was 14
but they I forget how old he is
so here at the new perhaps at Kevin
serves him in a sexual advance toward
him in 1986 man comes forward describing
alleged extended sexual relations so
they are conceptual they were dating
and then he's not consensual if you're
14 but well no you know I'm saying like
he didn't rape at 40 but then he told me
to come over came and then Kevin Spacey
tried [ __ ] him tried tried rape and
we tried leaving and that's when he came
out oh this is another guy this is like
I'm fired from Netflix not this again
this is the thing I was the nail in the
coffin yeah I I didn't I didn't read
this it's just the one that really did
him dirty so there's no absolutely
denies the allegations well but I mean
but but you you can't just say you
believe this kid even if it's true in a
court you can't be guilty like that
there's got to be evidence and due
process that's what the country we live
in you know I'm saying
here you go read this whole article be
yeah yeah read this and then then the
countless other people that can verify
this kid's story
this is what's gotten fired by the way
this is the big one this was a big one
yeah the kid was 14 they were in a
relationship
yeah and then he for some reason they
they had a falling-out Kevin asked them
to come back to his house came his house
he tried raping him the kid got away but
they had a relationship here right is
that what he's saying it that's good
yeah yeah yeah they did you were a
working child actor of course I have a
24 year old boyfriend I'm going to going
out to palm clubs I'm lying to my
parents about all this and I'm cheating
on my cousin boyfriend to go see Kevin
Spacey uh-huh I'm very caught up in the
drama it's not early winter so now I'm
15 hmm okay
penetrate you know I don't think so I
feel like that's a little iffy no I
don't think so
you gotta read the whole thing you guys
can't just jump to conclusions I don't
know we thought you were talking about
at the arap at first but not enough
runway yeah this is different this is
once this came out Netflix that was like
oh well yeah that's him Spacey I saw him
as a young man on many many occasions
great actor great actor so he doesn't
bounce back at all he's done done done
yeah not even after five years no
because I feel like these guys are so
talented that somewhere in Europe he
probably works in Europe I guarantee he
gets jobs in Europe he's just too good
not to
I guarantee they go you know
let's put them in livery Europe never
here little B variant CMAs ever here I
think blue ck be alright yeah I mean
Weinstein's awfully super [ __ ] wine
she's [ __ ] um species [ __ ] he's
[ __ ] huh I think also Cara Lee hi what
I've seen there's a lot of people just
don't like his whole crew comes out
against him yeah Bryan Cranston's is
like he's a he's a bad guy yeah everyone
says he's a damn that's when you're
really not gonna get he made that he
made everything toxic so that's the
other thing
right and then Louie and then you know
again with louis c.k i think he bounced
back in three years and has some killer
material about it although a lot is
materials creepy now when you watch it
when you know he's doing the stuff yeah
he's open monologue on saturday life
he'd seen that well that's the other
thing is like so much of it is about him
his material so it reflects back on him
so you wonder i don't know you wonder
sometimes if he's SME for science like
help no no I'm just saying like like if
you were somebody who had chronic
masturbator or whatever but you talked
about the world and you and you talked
about things that were outside of
yourself sometimes though when you've
compromised yourself that much now
you're giving your perspective it's it
might be a harder sell when you're kind
of a deviant it might not carry the same
way because there was something about
louis c.k that people like because he's
seen like a he was a genius he was kind
of like on the outside looking in but
there was also like an authenticity to
him yeah i think is me all right he's so
smart so brilliant it's such a good
stand up yeah I think he's be all right
I think so I drew this family let me put
it this way in five years if he puts out
a special about all this you gonna watch
it five years the long time well
whatever a year two years I'm I Amba
through you I bet it's gonna be a three
year cool let me ask you this - if he if
he's playing in a club somewhere he's
selling out don't you three years I'm
talking about right now right now I
don't know I think so I don't know what
middle America's thinking right now but
I think everybody's going [ __ ] it you do
the other day at this other yeah why
when I saw I don't think he has a ton of
female fans does he uh he did I know he
did mm-hmm he did you know cuz he talked
a lot about male hypocrisy ten across to
talked about metal artists we had a lot
of female fans in fact if you would look
specials it's a hundred percent 5050 men
and women I mean he was a champion I
must watch his last one yeah and so so
so with the show I did this weekend the
emcee goes late and gentlemen you seen
him all over the place
I had some troubles recently but give it
up for louis c.k announcing you know
just this like in the next Congress what
he just made a thing and and everybody
was like everybody went like this oh and
I was like really yeah really
of course it wasn't so the biggest thing
clubs will have them right
is it like would the comic store have if
Lewis cares that came out if I just drop
into a sit there like yeah can we wait a
little bit yeah I mean to bounce back
the only thing you can really do is what
therapy cuz it's not like there's not
many options you can have once you do
the deeds can you bounce back by just
saying it's my problem I have a weird
thing to me and I'm trying to get I'm
trying I'm in treatment that's all and
you got it you gotta wait get cool off
like three months and then do a PR stand
be like man got through treatment all
good you can't you can't you gotta go
back to normal life and you start
hitting the club yes
you can't yes we all get over it right
we're all like it's your golf you know I
mean I mean now you're making me laugh
and yeah it's your weird oh it's so
embarrassed if we're not the comedy
story comes in like now but any of those
but you can't go into treatment you no
matter how much treatment you have if
you [ __ ] 14 year olds yeah we're just
different game human beings are just
different game Americans are like no
awful you know it's just but they're
also in different lanes like you know
Kevin Spacey was it he he was a
phenomenal actor but he was it like
adderall if he was the head of a movie
if he's the lead you it wasn't like a
blockbuster hit TV is that's true yeah
that's true
and also TV if I have a theory I have a
thing he's super [ __ ] but he's
different because Louie CK has to sell
tickets right yeah it's more personable
and then Kevin Spacey you got these you
have a network behind you
I think what you're gonna see in about
three or four years is a production
company in France Italy Spain or the UK
and I think they're gonna have a TV show
and it's gonna be a sick show and you're
gonna see Kevin Spacey pop up I I
wouldn't be surprised if somehow he
finds his way back into the mix yeah
that's how it goes I mean yeah I don't
think that's like do you even Browns can
win the Super Bowl next year do you
think he is a tough question but do you
think do you want to see him never work
again I need to get more facts
yeah story see my thing is also busy a
pedophile anyone - yeah
or is he into guys so is he fun to your
kids is that what he does or is he into
[ __ ] men who eat why isn't channeled
like a healthy relationship with him
liking men so then the first guys he
sees what seems like a younger boy he
gets attracted to it he needs like
figure out his [ __ ] [ __ ] with his
homosexuality did you hear about his
childhood his dad was this huge like
you're not sad neo-nazi and abused him
and his brother he turned to acting
because it was his way of acting not
himself
yes his way of getting out of all of it
I've talked about three gay guys this is
terrible this is not data to even go by
but all three of them were adamant about
the fact that when you're 14 and you're
gay you're gay and the all three of them
do that
they all had older boyfriends right it's
like very very common for them to you
know and and that is you get sexualized
young as a gay man a lot of times
especially that girl dude I'm not saying
listen you're 14 yeah that's if you [ __ ]
the fourteen-year-old you know if you
just you can't be little straight oh my
god thank you again it's like hold on
you want like a DI man had sex ladies
girls this one [ __ ] was 14 what like
what what you know even 17 I know
there's an age of consent but if you're
a dude and there's a guy was talking to
one time who was 32 and he was talking
about how he had sex with a 17 year old
which is legal in Vegas and I was like
well I get it too but I just can't be
around you it's pretty weird I can't be
around well it's like the
all the kids from stranger things like
11 like this guy made a post it was all
over social media people were up in arms
about it because their sexualizing her
yeah 14 or 13 like come on man let me
kids yeah it's super weird getting super
weird one thing can't [ __ ] with ya yeah
you can't they're doing it to that other
kid too though Wolford the star the boy
the fat one no no no he's like the the
main star the one who is also in it yes
yeah yeah you know what the unset you
know the untold secret about all this is
and that that's just a fact there's a
biology involved so when you hit puberty
at 14 boy girl you are and especially
girls girls who hit puberty some girls
are fully mature if it was early early
children so biologically you've got an
into most of history and most societies
even today and a lot of countries that
that age is when you get married off
that age 14 15 is where you get and when
you start having kids on America know
but traditionally that was always the
case and including in America and
including in the UK and including in
everyone we're all VIN [ __ ] well
because you realize that that was for
trains not fully developed and they're
14 you're not making a choice and you're
getting married off to a 30 year old a
40 year old but that was the norm it was
uh hi let me ask you this so that that
boy that from it yeah there was a model
like 26 years old she's like when your
she tweeted like when you're four years
older gimme a call said people yeah
people were getting although yeah and
that was [ __ ] cuz she was just being
silly like okay that's what gets come it
here's the double standard because if a
guy yeah I'm male model tweeted at 11
went man when you're 18 give me a call
people he probably loses yeah exactly
with her were like oh it's all good
that's hilarious are you a date in and
it's fine and also I think we better
this is where I worry because humor and
any interpretation right now things are
so sensitive that it's like you know
everybody's terrified of everything and
I think that's not healthy either let's
all take it easy
nobody she's not a pedophile she was
[ __ ] just saying what she was saying
I've heard that a thousand times she's
not trying to sexualize the kid you know
give people the benefit of the doubt but
everybody is really up with this right
now everybody is you know everybody
everybody's got a story to tell
yeah I'm in the thick of it yeah and I
and in that case good people get
embarrassed good people get swept up in
the whirlwind I don't think that's
helpful you but also don't be stupid and
tweet that out yeah think of it man
tweet they do better though yeah it'll
be smarter this is new to trial trial by
Twitter it's on yeah but also no not to
tweet at a 14 year old that you want to
date them wall remem yeah that numbers
not good now that number if they're 14
also don't be an idiot
yeah just don't be a [ __ ] [ __ ] I
mean it you know what I'll give her the
benefit that I don't even think she was
I think there was all the last things
she was thinking about oh man you're
being too nice baby now I like the
limelight you have to tread on your
words lightly like you learned if you're
verified on Twitter and we're in the
middle and you're involved in
entertainment you know that moms moms
yeah yeah
clumsy [ __ ] um chin I got a lot of
questions at every show what's up with
chins dating life seriously every show
holy moly I said guys he's gay yeah guys
I said we have eHarmony is gay we've had
tinder he's been on toward me nothing I
know not gay I'm a virgin that's the one
that heard a lot from everyone like
four-year-old whatever it is it doesn't
matter something we love you but er me
is actually pretty crazy have you been
working all the crap there's like so you
know tinder swipe like crazy didn't get
any matches in once in a while they'll
come up but this one er me there's tons
really
tons of match against the ashes like 30
over 35 matches but those are just
matches the ones that are they actually
a mug message me does it show pictures
of them it does dude for sure bring up
on the screen pick why but we can't put
what no we all put on social media yeah
no I can't showed up here we'll do it if
we see it they won't see it right
alright so I didn't answer it is but
messages yet though but yes we just
don't show them the so you haven't
with Suzy matches there's like you are
it's kind of like tinder but more
serious yeah so these chicks are
actually looking for yeah what's a ray
are they're women they're hotties huh
that's it on the matches I'll keep going
damn Idol well damn Michelle's 48 she
does not know it's weird I put I put
like a filter 27 and 37 and then they
just kind of pick it just ignored it to
tell with these pictures you never know
what's going on yeah and then these are
the ones that actually messaged Oh
oh my she'll click on her she's okay so
you send smiles and stuff like weird oh
yeah she does not look 48 jokes once
again choice of hat well she's messing
around man looks like a nice woman
though exactly most of them look very
like they're nice people
yeah but not that's pretty much hey but
the horn let me see the profile go
another one let me see how this work so
they see your profile and then they okay
so question if you won the lottery how
would you spend your money all this
you're trying to get to know each other
that's what yeah so they're just asking
me that question so there's those are
probably like template questions but
then then making the effort to ask you
that guess that's their thing click on
did you guys I've got Judy's profile I
just saw this today - okay you're a
great fit along with a son all right
yeah really Brian um let me see her
profile though I'm sure how it's
different than tinder scroll down uh-huh
Pat all right she's passion about art
trial fitness finance I spent my leisure
time sketching exploring new places
learning something new likes to play
cycling skiing snow snowboarding bowling
running hiking
I'd be like enjoys watching tennis was
she the boyishly in the world um my
grandmother's taught me the value what
matters most in life yeah it's just more
realistic it's not like it's not like
you're trying to get dick sucked yeah
yeah you're looking for a real long
lasting relationship it's some deep [ __ ]
man
no wonder a bunch of people find their
loved ones on here so true yeah now and
go to our favorite shows I'll tell you
this gonna be a fit where is it I just
fantasy sci fi how they get detailed
here the other dude makes a lot of sense
you even have like we both read like
reading watching my buddy that's how he
he he found out his girl deeper set John
Irving fan and he was like boom and that
was it and they got married yeah these
days like this chin I don't look down
upon it I don't I'm on it man this is
good for you chin it is you want babies
and you want I don't want babies do you
want a lot of kids you want to be Papa
chin I don't want to be as you do yeah
you saw their matches chin let me see
the matches matches
oh-hoo-hoo see up there I was gonna say
37
JMC isn't mine she's yeah right
she's fine though yeah now first of all
master's degree believes in Jesus I
don't have kids I want kids that's
another weird thing they do drink
religions and the thing here have some
kids with her dude they ask you how
religious are you from like one to ten
or something so they get really specific
I put like the very city yes take Mara a
stroll as you scroll down to what else
did she say she enjoys concerts life
theater
I read enjoyed Game of Thrones one
through five and she says you know
nothing you know priests used to say
that when they would pray really hard
and nuns they would have their hands
would bleed that was always the way he's
to prove your pious s your hands would
plead because you had you know nails
chin are you're not feeling any of these
I honestly in that time yeah I barely
even look okay what do you been doing
huh I'm going out of town hey man I know
we say you don't have oh yeah hey dude
he needs time is doing some stuff mail
it's been yeah okay behind the scenes
here hey can you get a couple years you
can have that when he bites and he
throws bodies for tea oh my give him 10
years what's the big deal yeah yeah give
me nice browse eHarmony for 10 years
until he finds the perfect match
Jesus she's hot what's with her what's
the
I know but can he wait till he has to
get his prostate checked every [ __ ]
month
hey but horns go up but if you this
don't do that don't take that picture
yeah I'm exactly dude yeah that's an
issue yeah I don't do that Duke up see
up that Louie with a wig
it's very hard to find ones that are
even like decent like her oh it's easy
well that must go that's good bring her
up bring her up this one yeah that's
cute why would that one girl take a
picture of the flat-band how old are the
girls you're putting in what is it I put
27 at 30 look at 23 look at ya Chintan
load 21 well well um are you piss out
from do current events hold on what did
you do this weekend chin yeah it was a
general answer besides you said a bunch
of bunch of stuff to do I'm gonna be
chin ask me what I did
hey chill what'd you do this weekend I
moved around what's that even mean till
you move the houses no just kind of like
you know Chuck Chuck and Chuck around
you know all weekend pretty much most of
it did you have your cell phone on E
I think I did just general general el
general over there history
did you sing it or anything I just we
don't know what you my god is the
podcasting she goes hey can I go team
kill a lot of people would you say you
didn't uh birthday party yeah so
birthday party was just a dinner at
cream barbecue so wasn't a birthday
party it was more of a dinner yeah but
it was considered his birthday party
yeah is your friend yeah that's much of
our friends whenever we guy if I'm a cop
I can't solve any crime nothing the
birthday party but it was a dinner a
little guy as Goggin barbecue I say
Kramer you did that on Friday night that
was Saturday all right yeah what are you
doing Friday
what was that Friday you know you know
I'll go to the general area Friday
Saturday it might have been Friday cuz
no no it was Saturday because it was an
air of the fights yeah
wasn't that right we'll talk about that
yeah yeah and then Friday was what do
you do out chin thoughtfully killing
kids on the side here you worked all
right all right well you know that's the
chin some current events man can we just
talk about the fights real quick oh yeah
I have to watch in my green room you did
yeah I mean I had to I saw the matte
Brown knock out when I came back man and
then I saw the Poirier stuff I've only
seen clips the Poirier stuff but then
now that was a great fight good fight
they stood they stood up now pettis had
a triangle him but blood was running his
eye so so so so when Poirier looked
really really good and he was punching
him punching him up got him on the
ground executed a bunch of takedowns and
then dropped an elbow and cut his bad
blood was in his eyes and then blood was
everywhere and you could hear him say
you know cuz Pettis had really deep
triangle a couple times but he slipped
out because he's just slippery the blood
made every blood boil
yeah then he had him in a body guard
like a body lock and he turned over and
Pettis tapped I think he pulled
cartilage or did something ribeye her
this was a rib yeah but I guess it
didn't he didn't break the rib okay what
Nate Nate the greatly good he's [ __ ]
lost we look good right did man make a
hundred percent he was a winner for him
and he lost him is like another really
close match like the way the one he had
with Vitor I know it's I know - laughs
what decision the man he's in the Mex is
he in the mix of well I mean just you
know he's already fight so many fights
but yeah I don't know he's made the
great you know yep but not Matt Brown
that elbow oh it seems like they're
friends or something do they train
together there's a lot of love there
with I believe Diego Sanchez has the
most number of recorded hours in the
cage for a welterweight certainly GSP
does okay but but he may have it his all
time he has all time are you sure
positive most minutes inside the cages
be okay cuz they had there was a stat
when he wants to
yeah I thought was a mimosa for a time
can you look that up Jo Sanchez but he
be GS B's is that Wow yeah those just be
for most time yeah he spent like over 50
minutes and so so many so many so that
was a crazy elbow Jesus Christ that was
just a crazy elbow and you know was I am
I crazy er was Matt Brown actually
thinking about retiring for he wanted to
retire he did okay
so Frankie Edgar's number one Micra
Bisbee number two just P number three
Wow I think just B's the most in the
champ ship rings Diego Sanchez is like
eight down be nine down is that right is
that five hours and 38 minutes yeah
that's how Frank Jaeger six hours holy
[ __ ] like a Bisbing Jeremy Stephens more
than Diego Sanchez I would never have
guessed that neither one you'd be
fighting for a while
Wow Wow they're good though I agree to
Clay Guida looking look you had that
uppercut and sent Joe lose ons head like
literally through them old timer
scrapping it out yeah I looked out of it
- the whole time he looked drawn out I
like him man who was this both those
goes on yeah
his eyes were like hollow yeah that was
a crazy punching I turn avenge in sure
what happens with Pettis now keeps
fighting yeah yeah
how many see how many I see oneness did
he win his last wonder he lose his last
one no he lost max Holloway
I think Cup day and went back to 55
right what do you got Jin let's just
take a look at this rare frilled shark
real cool assaults on Twitter's thing
sick caught off Portugal it's just
rarely seen he is it huge
I know six for 1.5 meters okay they say
as long as a man yeah wait so caught in
the depth of 700 meters and look at his
mouth hasn't changed over a million
years huh they say we never see him cuz
they're so goddamn deep long echoes the
New Zealand Africa deep Foster Leah
super deep well there you go
in Japan yeah got a hollow mouth he got
washed up
the shore right that's how we found him
I think they caught it looks like a
tremor the frilled shark it sure does
look like a truck has 25 rows teeth it
sure does look like a tremor that's
probably where they got the idea huh
probably out River frozen dirt mm-hmm
looks like a big slippery greasy dick -
well Jeff that thing for those warts or
fins bro I don't know what else you got
you the thing's pretty gnarly looking
yeah all right so first one a boxing
coach named Ramon Sosa Wow he faked his
own death geez there isn't a hole with a
bloody bloody head shot wound to the
head
have you heard about this bee I have I
read a little bit about it it's
hilarious man so he met this hot chick
in 2007 ended up marrying her in 2010
and then started having like financial
troubles so she immediately wanted
divorce him as soon as that happened and
then she tried to find someone who had
like a bit like a shady background to
hire him
or to find someone to hire to kill her
husband so he'd get the insurance money
but she hired his friend she didn't know
that in his frank always handy I knew
him because I coached him he'd been in
trouble in the past the first one he
called and said he needed to see me
because someone wanted to kill me I
thought he was joking
then we devised a plan she's a sociopath
yes so then they tell the cops go hey
just to make it worse like let's take
pictures so it looks like killed her so
you know Wow and they show their picture
and start laughing yeah she did
yeah watch your hair this is what she
found out Maria Sosa is talking about
her husband though she thinks is dead in
a shallow grave scene laughing at a
picture of what she thought was the
murdered body of the man she married
[ __ ] man it's a long story but yeah dude
look at how she's laughing just that bad
her she joked he's not gonna he's not
gonna come out of the hole
wow what a sweet woman well she got 20
years is that enough no give her I'm not
she doesn't she wanted him dead 20 years
is not enough she's a piece of [ __ ] and
this guy he's
how do you live after that like happily
knowing that your wife wanted to kill
you you're fine man guess once you're
alive this dis [ __ ] you got her out
of your life got a great story
oh yeah Sin City but also change your
ways so [ __ ] don't want to kill you
what do you do well you know she's
probably a very manipulative person is
great in bed killers can probably you
know she can getcha
yep jay-z look at her nice that's them
look at her she was happier times I know
happier time the force you wanna know
about it
really good well the I hate the cops
help them he does a hole they helped him
with the blood they looked at actual
pictures of people murdered yeah and
matched it looks like yeah I like if I
look like him I we can just keep my head
still my titties are sticking out man
hello guys as a boxer myself I have a
lot of like feeling for this right now
we looked at this one last time right
this this Navy US Navy sailor cut trying
to hire a hitman
or maybe I'll watch that I don't know no
I he's he get Scott to sing [ __ ] he's
talking to inform it and he's like I
need you to kill my wife and man I
believe you should go to jail for life
when you it's it's a murder if you're
trying to just have that person killed
I'm just not doing it correct what else
you got Jen please tell me a dead crab
with the bird I do
[Music]
funny the crab just on first
well OJ Simpson is officially banned
from the Cosmopolitan Hotel and Casino
cuz apparently he was getting drunk and
causing a ruckus all the bars inside
cosmopolitan I mean dear Ted in Vegas to
cause a ruckus is that true that's good
so it's alleged it's alleged but he is
if I just don't want to met the bark is
bad for business that's probably what I
probably get the [ __ ] is it bad for
business I think it's her business I
feel I could be bad but wouldn't all of
us be like like okay watch except for
white roses over there what I'm going
over there right now if we're getting a
drink I got it not me I wouldn't do that
I would I go where's yeah I would look
if I want
around no not only I bet you people mob
him for pictures don't let me get a
picture it must be exhausting well well
well there you go and let's go to the
bird right now okay so you know coconut
crabs are oh yeah I've seen her Janice
was in Tahiti I've seen them part with
my own [ __ ] what to say so a
researcher was filming this crab it went
up a tree and saw a boo-boo bird nesting
he grabbed it by the wing and then they
fell to the ground and then he started
chopping his wings off they are tearing
up the crab grabs the bird breaks his
wings so he can't fly with Absalon let's
go ahead and see that the birds like
she's barely so you really see I'll show
you a little bit of this clip look at
that gnarliest dude there I told you
they're this big they're so scary yeah
see the birds pecking at the crab if the
crab have them on the wing so he's just
holding her that's what the majority of
the video is holding that sucks
death by wing yeah those crabs eat meat
that's the thing so the researcher found
this there's like it's a super rare
discovery but as he was filming as the
night went on there's other crabs that
came towards the commotion and they all
started eating the bird yeah oh that
scares me they come out of the woodwork
the poor bird giant spiders how's your
dating goons giant spiders eating you
oh that's terrif write your [ __ ]
wings off so I can't fly away well
that's awful and they all came out of
the woodwork to show more skin oh yes it
sucks but this is again this guys are
legit researcher yeah man course I
thought we were all terrified why are
they so yeah it's so big dude there's
people or no well why don't you bring up
it's not my fingers in it take a look at
how big they are huge oh but slow though
right mmm that's all as an expert I can
tell you um they're [ __ ] huge man
they're so big yeah there you go
so joy on there and by the way they hang
out on [ __ ] trees look at the size of
that thing
they're cool I'm not scared and you know
it kills a lot of baby sea turtles crabs
so they they wait let's just show zero
in on one of those pictures I mean
they're not like aa picture the size
that [ __ ] thing they're huge
I mean yeah they supposed taste like
coconut they're [ __ ] delicious that's
we kill but they're protected their
protector yeah they're not on Islands
damn well you that one on the trash can
oh yeah we saw this one time ago I think
God dog I mean come on good
walking crush your dog I just stab it
Wow they've been known to kill just yet
chin let's see okay there was an
undercover investigation on TSA and have
cording to the investigation like 80% of
the stuff they wanted to get through got
through contraband illicit stuff hmm
so this guy Schumer is calling for an
overhaul yeah something like 90 percent
so you know how they try to get by TSA
saying TSA doesn't catch like 90% of the
things that they should it's all that
waiting [ __ ] what are you doing yeah
yeah no [ __ ] that doesn't surprise no
like sometimes I get by with someone
like yeah yeah TSA screening may feel as
much as 80% of the time I tweed the
sound just but no [ __ ] it's just yeah
well you see the people working in
there's some have power trips and you
know some are great guys and I see them
all the time as we travel some great
guys then some all right you know belts
off but you don't come in water shoes
off get in line you know I'm like Jesus
Christ bro you don't have a bad why are
you acting like there I feel like the
machines are made to catch like
explosives and guns and stuff right I
mean I don't know now they're sneaking
guns through if you read this thing
they're sneaking guns through all sorts
undercover operatives
able to smuggle contraband contraband is
what like weapons right yeah but yeah
anything that's on that list of
explosives liquids
but what can you do is crazy bro part of
this bar the biz part of the biz I will
you do take boats which you want and
this comes out right before the holidays
that's the biggest traveling size what
else you get oh okay have you guys heard
of this story before a guy catching his
wife cheating on him with a drone huh no
you never seen this no this is a man's
watch this and this mine
this guy's amazing TV we must be a beast
with the drone he Turner does it for a
living
okay they go you ever watch those drone
races you know obstacle course right
Lynch it and they have the teams are in
these weeds and they're like going
through these crazy yeah yeah super
nerdy yeah check this up hey guys I'm
yog and he looks like a Drona my wife's
been cheating on me yep great right yeah
a quarter meeting a guy only a few
blocks from my home and I got it on
video here's the video all right so
we're gonna pick this up right here she
leaves a hole all the way down here and
around to the CVS parking lot up there
I'm gonna fast-forward it even though
it's in fast motion otherwise we'll just
be here forever it'll be a long boring
video I like this right here where she's
walking this way usually she walks this
way to go to work over here so when I
first saw this I knew something was up
and I started to get a little bit upset
and sure enough she was going to to uh
to meet this on the highway and here she
is waiting at the at the intersection
waiting at the life will appears what it
seems like forever and here she is
taking her hair out it's got to make
yourself look pretty got to make
yourself look pretty for the for the guy
you're about to cheat on your husband
with right yeah make sure your hair is
all nice she brushing her hair on even
though she's doing she's making her hair
she's pulling her hair out then brush
your hair [ __ ]
now she walks across the street and this
guy is hiding behind the the CBS and
he's and so she gets here he's gonna
come back come out so I'm assuming she's
on the phone with him that's the old day
I could assume oh here it is in a hotel
well there's the guy told that my wife
is cheating on me with my wife of 18
years and watch
watch carefully you're gonna be able to
see 18 years go right down the [ __ ]
drain watch if you're not paying
attention you might miss it here it
comes
there it goes Oh 18 years gone
18 years of just thrown away like that
18 years
well I'll update and he put it up on
video huh
well yeah you would yeah there were
cheating nerds oh sorry so the update
was that was actually a year ago and
then a story came out that he's back
together yeah he finally took her back
is that her he's a good-looking handsome
guy and the cheating was just a they
have no evidence of anything else other
than she picked him on the lips that was
it like three times what do you think
they did when they went off in that bar
it's all good yeah the figured out Li
the big man doing the look at the drone
master I bet she's triggered by drones
now walked in the street yeah you know
18 years you get a little past sometimes
you move just sigh Kamala's work through
this 18 years a long time to [ __ ] just
one person right yeah Plus drones are
super sexy he said the drones saved
their marriage by putting an end to the
secret relationship she had or the
secret of sunshine [ __ ] before it really
got serious I feel like he's aging like
why and she's aging like fruit he's a
good-looking guy nice with the drones
yeah nice he's tall and she's I know you
guys seen this ready right gal gadot she
says you will not work will not do
Wonder Woman too if Brett Ratner's apart
of it so little I know somehow I know
some inside stuff about this and one of
the things Brett did is he he financed
the directors first movie and has always
been super good to Patty and so it's a
complicated
thing because I was sick I didn't know
he was on board anyway why is he those
small parties on board right he just
like you said financing his production
team it like finance half of the movie
or half of the half of financing for the
first movie was his production team Oh
to do that she won't do the movie you
can't have wonder one really without her
yeah and it would be very bad to have
one or one more Siskel this what all the
women have rallied around like that the
second sequel it's like you got it just
say I get it you you can't she's a
[ __ ] I've only spent a little time to
know she's a great person and her
husband's a great guy with type moves
you know what a power again yeah she's
got on with the crowd over at all the
power she's good people I can't imagine
them be like you know what we can go
someone else then rate he bred involved
those two yeah
now I haven't I didn't follow too much
of the Ratner thing Ratner wasn't that
wasn't it what was he is like Weinstein
or was he more like Weinstein 210
Ratner's a nine right really oh yeah
horrible [ __ ] hmm all right we've talked
about this today yeah people probably
funky is a [ __ ] you know yeah so six
women on Brett right now okay check this
out there's a boat race over the weekend
in the Key West see some race I haven't
seen it check it out [ __ ] man
[Music]
wait for it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so boat I guess doesn't see the boat in
front of them and just use it as a ramp
god damn and the the motor and the back
didn't [ __ ] up the the boat that a
motor Chuck heads off
everyone was alright yeah that's not too
crazy really you know standard boat
ready ride over no one's hurt no both
got destroyed another margin
why is this big this is big on Instagram
a lot of people are showing it oh yeah
so it's slowed down there it's really
fast if you see it in fast mode even
less impressive
I guess you just couldn't handle it he's
passed out and went over I can't see cuz
those windows are tiniest [ __ ] well you
know what movie I watched on the plane
was that big stick jet aft as new movie
the big sick yeah have you seen it now
yeah big sick best exactly still BIG's
big sick have you seen it no wha
have you guys seen it I know a lot about
it they were down yeah it's a real true
story it's a true story how the the main
character met his wife and he's Muslim
and he meets this white girl and his
family base he disowns I'm stuff like
that and then he tells this white girl
that he can't be with her because you
know he'll lose his family so they kind
of separate and then she gets super sick
goes into coma she almost dies that's
the movie and he gets close with his
parents and then she comes out of the
coma she almost dies comes out of the
coma and then you know I don't want
spoilers yeah I've watched like yeah I
was super sad for a while it's good cuz
they're stand-up it it's a really well
done movie it's really really good but
it was and speaking of which did they
pull I love you daddy
is that done it's not not going in the
movie theaters let me see kids movie
it's just done and he financed it they
just pull it out they just pull it out
so it works with it Wow and it does
there's some scenes in there though that
are questionable yeah but it doesn't go
anywhere it doesn't like nah I think you
could release it on his website I think
he's been doing the ickey released some
stuff on his own he's been doing that
for a while
yeah yeah
daddy's gone no they must have known all
this was coming too because they were
having meetings way before when once
they found out the New York Times is
working on this story it's good they
were once he got busted but he said it's
a witch hut only if your witch she's
like witches you're scared
yeah let us get in for sure don't show
me a boat just race another boat jumping
over it I'll let you see this headline
gay lions spotted having sex in the
Savannah Kenya an official is outraged
so now we're talking Maine on Maine bro
a Kenyan official what's crazy gay lions
ISIL well of course he does this is
immoral [ __ ] unbelievable you got
demons also in habitat animals oh this
is a Anti prayer anti-gay stuff is alive
and well in Africa um yeah so Wildlife
Photographer caught that David he put if
our lines begin this homosexual behavior
then that will surely be the end of the
animal species oh my god this guy sounds
brilliant
he sounds brilliant he wants some
isolated in case you catch gay hold up
this dude put it was just dramatic thing
to see he was astonished by mythology
March to learn it's not normal these
animals need counseling because probably
they have been influenced by gays who
have gone to the national parks and bow
put him on he's right there it's a long
interview though and he sounds like he's
sword 1/2 being silly but half serious
okay let me see maybe he's joking around
so it's 7 minutes long this guy has a
humorless you hard to understand this
guy that's the worst of it maybe he's
joking around
I mean oh he actually tweeted so this is
official Twitter our lines begin this
show I think he's choking that's funny
I think he's joking that
did you see [ __ ] a did you see
Trump's tweet about Kim jong-un yeah was
so funny to me though that was a funny
cuz I can't believe he would call me old
I would never call him short and fat I
hope we can be friends one day did you
see it no it's a [ __ ] great see this
what are you doing on the weekend cuz
this made me laugh so hard this I
thought this was a great every person in
the world saw this I thought this is a
great tweet I thought it was just
[ __ ] hilarious Korean - this is this
is good comedy I'm sorry
Trump sarcastic it responds - when will
the haters and fools out there no that's
fine that's fine that's different yeah
why would Kim Jung hoon insult me by
calling me old when I would never call
him short and fat oh well I try so hard
to be his friend and maybe someday that
will happen [ __ ] genius it almost
made me a trump then but I'm not I mean
he's the president of these United with
I know what else you got uh well you
guys brought up Trump so you know he
actually talked to the Chinese president
about releasing those guys yeah yeah you
know they're looking at twenty years or
ten years if they're if they're fully
like whatever goddamn China relax yeah
but have you heard the rumors that they
stole more than like once some three
times three times anyhow my baton I
think right there's a loose on the
tracks do sunglasses on it might be a
you face ten years of prison what the
[ __ ] is this bald kid think he's a kid
they have money
yes stealing uh sunglass normally
Vuitton can sunglasses what in the world
are you thinking if you're in China
trying to steal it's kind of crazy I
don't know so yeah the president said
they're gonna get a fair trial
yikes which means what you get five
years [ __ ] so they are going to trial
though hold on that was mighty am i
speaking so they'll be treated fairly
and
the fact that the president's looking
into it just let him pay a fine that's
the most powerful man China really
doesn't work like that
no they execute people yeah they cut
your heads off they've executed I don't
know about that but I don't actually
give more people than any other country
Jesus China and they sell your organs
what now your organs go on the old
market the old way need a kidney a
couple bad people we caught some people
who got some people stealing corruption
they kill people for corruption executed
for credible yep
vixx cute more people than the rest of
the world huh combined yeah it's also a
lot of people by the way by the way yeah
but how much more is it then everyone
else well no well these several thousand
people in a out of a bit over a billion
yeah it's not it's not that much and
let's be honest 2000 people probably
deserve to die yeah we all know somebody
who could die all of us know somebody a
good time we'd be like really cool
everybody that it that's it it drop
gnaws be yeah this is fascinating about
did you read it laugh though I know I
hope not
um just a little thing about women and
so since women are in the day and sexual
harassment all but it's pretty
interesting how in the u.s. women were
only allowed to have credit cards in
their own name as of forty three years
ago men had a two decade head start when
was the credit card invented anybody
know give me an e give me a year thought
this was kind of interesting 1950 yeah
[ __ ] you what don't see my phone no what
I see is your little sneak no you're a
road puppy sneak that's why no that's
pretty common man all right in the
nineteen sixties a woman needed to bring
a man along to co-sign on any credit
application that makes sense
and then this is also connect to the
fact that women didn't have bodily off
but dude women didn't have bodily
autonomy either do you know what that
was
okay meaning a woman's husband could
beat her or have sex with that with her
without her consent in this country with
no real legal recourse until the 1970s
that's great we've come a long way in a
short period of time he's that's that's
that's [ __ ] fascinating you know so
yeah I just thought it'd be bringing
streetcars in 1950 yeah you could rape
women neither bring somebody along when
I was born this country that's right yep
that's right way to empty a job well
done new bride to work hmm hey man it's
not a competition
don't give her the nod don't give it
back in 1950 you guys come see me this
Friday Saturday Gotham comedy club oh I
love a see me at the Gotham comedy club
Friday Saturday I got two shows Friday
to show Saturday I'm excited take us a
teef at kake.com
look oh club.com I'm excited I got a
post about that today again and and
there you have it you little monkeys oh
and then I'll be in Utah at wise guys in
Salt Lake [ __ ] City
Friday Saturday after Thanksgiving
Thanksgiving weekend then I'm at cobs
December 7 8 and 9 in San Francisco so
come see me boom I'm an empire inland
Inland Empire Ontario improv November
30th that is my next show but then guess
what what find kid alive we back
together December 5th at the Comedy
Store in Los Angeles [ __ ] our first
thought about that I've seen all the
weekends stressing me out it's gonna be
fun yeah it's gonna be final it could be
a disaster I'm just kidding the fire in
the kid is live at The Comedy Store
December 5th it is one show one night
only you know that [ __ ] gonna get
tickets right now to you outcome so on
I'm at the Ontario improv my next shows
no van
xxx and then Brian and I are together
the fighter and the kid live become sore
December 5th then Buffalo I'm at the
helium December 14th through the 16th
get tickets right now tik calm for all
that juicy style shoes he [ __ ]
this is a fine kid we're out